c'est bien bon soir diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs
nous sommes ce soir en direct de vichy
or je suis avec le grand maître et loire
lange en soirée loi bonsoir
stéphane bonsoir à tous donc spécial
diagonale pendant six jours à vichy avec
donc des placements de matériels humains
et techniques pourtant oui alors toute
l'équipe de diagonale et ici à vichy
accompagné de deux donc un réalisateur
un ingé son beaucoup de matériel tout ça
pour vous faire vivre les moments les
plus forts de ce grand tournoi de cet
événement national qui est donc le
championnat de france d'échecs 2000
championnat du millénaire j'aime pyla du
millénaire championnat très importants
on va évidemment y revenir toute la
semaine je rappelle que haut à la vidéo
on à jean-françois paris et aux sons
jérôme ardouin qui ont amené donc tout
un matériel important don pour faire
suivre en direct de vichy donc c'est la
première fois qu'on vient dire est aussi
long et loi sur un tournoi on a fait
donc les retransmissions de grand prix
sur deux ou trois jours mais là c'est
six jours de déplacement c'est pas
évident oui ils le savent être un peu
différent de ce qu'on a déjà fait
puisque normalement on fait des parties
en direct là on aura les joueurs qui
viendront nous commenter leur parti
commenter les événements et veut
évidemment on verra toutes les
évolutions du classement on verra qui
est en tête pour l'instant il ya donc
etienne bacrot qui en difficulté
puisqu'il n'est pas en tête il n'est que
troisième enfin on va y revenir de toute
façon ya un très beau plateau cette
année au national et je pense qu'on va
accueillir quelqu'un qui va nous en
parler avec avec beaucoup de
beaucoup de talent beaucoup de talent on
va évidemment parler donc de en premier
lieu de comment se place nationale
comment ça se déroule comment on peut
jouer ce national son historique aussi
avec le rien - mais que l'organisateur
en chef de cet événement l'a déjà reçu
sur des monnaies les lois c'est le
président de la fédération française
monsieur loubatières merci monsieur le
batteur nous rejoindre donc jean claud
battières président la fédération qui va
nous parler maintenant de ce national
avec toutes les les arcanes de
l'organisation de cet événement leur
bonsoir jean claude bonsoir alors
comment ça se passe au national donc on
l'a on arrive faut le rappeler on arrive
en milieu en fait du tournoi puisque la
première semaine s'est déroulée oui donc
les nationales c'est d'abord cette les
16 meilleurs joueurs français
à une exception près et il y avait au
départ de groupe de huit joueurs dans
chacun des groupes
c'est un tournoi tu te rends tous les
joueurs se rencontrent et puis au bout
des sept rondes
les quatre premiers de chacun des
groupes se retrouvent en poule haute
donc on est maintenant aux premiers
bilans et vont commencer les parties
capitale pour le titre alors aujourd'hui
c'est un jour de repos donc tous les
plus joueurs de tous les tournois donc
il ya plusieurs tournants on va en
parler puisqu'on va présenter un peu ce
national pour plus de monde ici présents
puisque je crois qu'il ya près de 1000
joueurs tous tournois confondus
il ya en fait exactement 9 144 joueurs
c'est le deuxième meilleur score de
l'histoire deux premiers sets et mille
neuf était puis le troisième score
c'était 891 à l'entente 93 donc c'est un
excellent score au niveau de la quantité
des joueurs et puis c'est le record
absolu au niveau de la force
c'est le plus fort national de tous les
temps les lots moyens et supérieurs de
1500 c'est aussi le plus fort tournoi
féminin de tous les temps les lots moyen
supérieur à 2200 c'est la plus forte
accession de tous les temps de grands
maîtres dans l'accession et 17 mètres
internationaux donc ça fait rêver
d'avoir un tournoi réserve
de cette qualité et puis bon l'open à
l'open d'écossé sont aussi très fort
donc c'est vraiment le tournoi delà du
millénaire certainement on va parler
d'abord on va présenter les tous les
tournois on va parler d'abord du tournoi
phare c'est évidemment le national donc
seize joueurs et on peut les citer citer
tous ils sont heureux c'est ignore
joueurs français donc voilà je crois que
le les tournois étaient organisés de
façon à ce que le spectacle soit le plus
depuis fort possible ça veut dire que
les appariements étaient orientés et
donc dans la septième ronde
on les deux meilleurs joueurs de chaque
poule se rencontrer donc on avait d'une
part christian bauer qui jouait contre
dorfman donc la partie a été nul et puis
la deuxième dans l'autre groupe
etienne bacrot qui était en tête
rencontré jean-marc degraeve et l'a donc
surprise de ce tournoi
etienne bacrot a été battu par jean-marc
des veuves donc c'est une surprise mais
jean-marc de grève avait les blancs il
est très fort on sait et pour la petite
histoire c'est la deuxième fois que
cette mésaventure arrive à etienne
bacrot puisque l'an passé il avait
également perdu la dernière partie de la
phase préliminaire
alors on va on va revenir sur la liste
de ces de tous et de tous ces joueurs à
noter que tout à l'heure on va recevoir
jean-marc degraeve à 21h30
accompagné de laurent guitare et lee et
à 22h robert fontaine et christian bauer
viendront aussi commenté leur parti donc
je suppose que jamais de gran augmentera
sa victoire contre etienne bacrot qui
est un moment important de ce tournoi
alors les joueurs d'abord dans la poule
a on va commencer dans l'alphabet on va
retrouver alors arnaud hauchard qui fait
un excellent tournoi puisque
actuellement il est en tête
enfin il a fini en tête de sa poule donc
c'est ça avec 55 points sur cette hausse
est possible
oui on aurait regagné ses trois
premières parties donc
avec un peu de chance puisqu'il a gagné
une partie quand igor nataf dans la
qualité complètement foutu mais enfin
bon ça fait partie du jeu et ensuite il
a assuré donc il a fait des nuls
uniquement des nuls et des nude souvent
rapides alors il est il se pose quand
même maintenant candidat sérieux au
titre puisqu'il est en tête et c'est un
joueur qui est très difficile à battre
nos maisons qui fait des nuls eu assez
souvent quand il est en difficulté il
arrive à tenir
voilà tout à fait alors donc arnaud
hauchard igor nataf qui pour la première
fois fait le national je crois c'est la
première fois qu'ils jouent le tournoi
ouais oui tout à fait il gare ne voulait
pas jouer cette année bon j'ai réussi à
les convaincre mais je crois que une
année très près quand on en a parlé cet
après midi en fait tu poses on sait que
c'est un joueur extrêmement talentueux
et puis c'est un joueur lui qui joue
c'est parti la forme qui qui croient je
crois qu'il est habité par les échecs
qui donne une énergie colossale
donc il devait dans ce national il y est
et puis sans début a été un peu
difficile
notamment il a perdu la partie contrant
nouveau char et puis bon il a encore
remporté une victoire décisive contre
jean-marc de grève qui l'a remis en
selle et la dernière ronde y jouer
contre marc siano
alors ce match a été passionnant parce
que les deux joueurs se rencontrer et il
fallait absolument que marc siano gagne
sinon il n'allait pas dans le coup le
final et la table lui de les faire nul
donc on a eu une partie et qui a été
théorique jusqu'au 26e coup c'était la
partie des favoris ça veut dire qu'ils
connaissent les coups c'est ça c'était
exactement la reproduction de la partie
au tilleul fans jusqu'au 25e coup ça
s'est joué en une minute
les 25 premiers coups à une minute donc
envoyé le temps puisque avec le système
qui gère les le temps de m'en envoyer le
temps des deux jacky qui augmentait
c'était
intéressante et puis très rapidement en
fait la taf se trouve être mal très mal
et lutter pour la lune nullité il a
trouvé des ressources et à un moment
donné ma il a fallu il a fallu pour marc
siano prendre des risques ou alors c'est
nuls ou alors il prenait des risques il
est rentré dans un réseau de maths et
igor la table a maté donc une partie
très tendue donc entre igor nataf et
marciano qui a décidé finalement de la
qualification de nataf pour la plus
haute tout à fait six heures de jeu il
faut pour la petite histoire il faut
dire que david marciano qui est un
joueur solide avait fait six parties
nulles avant et donc la septième par
contre il s'était encore nul mais il a
dû se suicider pour tenter de se
qualifier
donc il aurait dû aussi de gagner avant
ses intérêts mais bon c'était c'est pas
exactement son style alors ensuite je
fais dans l'ordre de la poule on trouve
évidemment la star des échecs français
actuel peut-être avec joël lautier qui
est etienne bacrot le champion de france
en titre donc il joue pour garder son
titre donc
etienne bacrot qui est là qui fait un
bon tournoi finalement mais ils vont ils
se qualifient évidemment enfin
évidemment en tout cas c'était supposé
au départ il qualifie avec 4 points et
demi donc il est qu un demi point des
premiers finalement il n'est pas loin il
n'a perdu qu'une partie donc on en a
parlé contre jean-marc degraeve donc à
suivre de près évidemment la prestation
détiennent dans la poule haute
ensuite jean marc degraeve donc qu'ils
se qualifient là on a les quatre
premiers de cette de cette poule a et
ensuite donc on va trouver donc marciano
qui a raté donc finalement sa
qualification la partie contre lyon
nataf on vient d'en parler et loire
linge notre co commentateurs qui fait le
tournoi alors est-ce que c'est pas dur
pour lui il peut être à votre avis la
deux oui on a trouvé eloi un petit peu
trop pacifiste c'est clair peut-être
qu'il pensait à autre chose et donc en
particulier le dernier jour et jouer
avec les blancs contre arnaud hauchard
est bon il essaie il a convenu d'une
rapide nullité n'est ce pas alors que un
joueur genre de compétitions de haut
niveau
pleinement joueur de compétition de haut
niveau se seraient battus pour se
qualifier
bon faut dire qu'il doit effectivement
pense un peu à des gones à la canalette
ça lui prend un peu évidemment de son
énergie et donc il a réussi quand même
une bonne prestation fils un peu en
dessous de son de son niveau puisqu'il
est il fait une performance en dessous
de son niveau et l'eau ensuite on trouve
d'arcoa nietzsche qui avait fait un très
bon championnat les dernières il me
semble qu'il est arrivé en demi finale
je crois oui d'arcole l'année passée
avait gagné sans son groupe avec six
points sur 7 et une performance de crois
que c'était 2816 ce qui est pas mal et
l'estonie qu'ils voulaient sa dernier
malheureusement il a eu beaucoup de mal
à entrer dans le tournoi il a perdu sa
première partie et ensuite il n'a jamais
pu revenir et on fait on trouve un
joueur donc qui est là qui n'est pas
titre est donc là il faut peut-être en
parler on va y revenir tout à l'heure
c'est laurent guidarini alors comment un
joueur non titré petit jour national
alors bon c'est quand même beau joueur
assez fort puisqu'il à 2300 points elo a
à peu près un peu moins est bon ils
terminent derniers m'ont mis sans être
ridicule puisqu'il fait une perf au
niveau de son lots à 2300 points dernier
cette poule heures comment ce joueur se
retrouve un national et bien c'est aussi
un des intérêts de la formule cette
formule est ouverte
en fait les joueurs sont qualifiés par
leur part leurs résultats des années
précédentes les deux précédents
champions les meilleurs lots les grands
maîtres et il ya quand même deux places
qui sont réservés aux vainqueurs de
l'accession de l'année précédente
donc il ya un tournoi qui s'appelle
l'autre mon accession et qui permet aux
deux premiers d'être qualifié pour
l'année suivante
voilà c'est un tournoi qui est très fort
l'année passée il était déjà très fort
d'ailleurs puisqu'il y avait l'année
passée un grand maître et 11 mètres
internationaux il était très fort mais
ce grand maître et séances de maîtres
internationaux ont été battus par deux
jeunes joueurs lorrains laurent guide
alité le laurent guy dallaire et 10 qui
n'est pas à titrer mais qui qui a gagné
le tournoi avec guillaume vallet et tous
les deux sont deux jeunes joueurs qui
sont très talentueux qui ont battu les m
donc laurent guidarini dans cette poule
a donc vainqueur d'accession de l'année
dernière donc c'est pour ça qu'ils
jouent le championnat
à noter que cette année on l'avait dit
le ton accession est très fort et il ya
beaucoup plus de mettre d'accord plus
les années dans de grands maîtres et 17
mètres internationaux c'est faible
d'ailleurs
jean-luc chavanon pas fait la une je
crois du magazine de la fédération a
tout à fait qui a réalisé une norme dont
aussi jean-luc serait quatre fois
champion de france marc centre romand
trois fois champion de france nicolas
giffard deux fois champion de france et
lui ross champion de france donc c'est 4
7 et de 9 et un 10 10 dix titres de
champion de france qui sont en accession
aidée champion de france assez récent ce
qui prouve le renouvellement très fort
des échecs français
oui donc parce que les anciens champions
doivent se qualifier maintenant c'est de
plus en plus du réseau et avoir des
dérogations pour les quand même pour les
enseignantes pas de sénateur à la
fédération il faut gagner sa place sur
l'échiquier
alors on passe mes talents groupe b on a
présenté les joueurs du groupe a avec
alors c'est aussi un espoir alors on va
retrouver deux espoirs importants aux
deux premières places des jeux de france
et actuel puisque on a le le français
christian bauer qui était le seul
français qualifié aux championnats du
monde de las vegas il avait gagné sa
place le seul français à avoir gagné sa
place je crois que je vais loti au site
est qualifié mais quand ça sert ont
délogé par sa légende donc christian
bauer qui termine aussi avec comme
meurent nos chars avec cinq points sur 7
dont qui fait un très bon tournoi avec
une performance à plus de deux mille six
cent soixante deux mille six cent
soixante trois points exactement de
performance c'est un très bon début de
tournoi pro vie christian est très fort
toute façon il se place un petit peu en
favori puisqu'il est un premier ex-aequo
avec arnaud hauchard mais il a progressé
énormément donc il a joué récemment des
tournois comme l'open de new york où il
a rencontré beaucoup de grands maîtres
au dessus de 2600 en gagnant en faisant
nul
il a joué les championnats d'europe
individuels où il a joué presque à
chaque ronde des joueurs au dessus de
1600 il n'a pas perdu une partie
donc il a vraiment progressé énormément
est ici dans ce tournoi il a montré ses
qualités vont ces qualités sont des
qualités de battant est accrocheur jeudi
ans n'a jamais gagné comme christian il
faut faut se battre jusqu'au bout
il a été en particulier très mal qu'on
nomme deux parties contre freyssinet et
contre valserres et il a sauvé les deux
fois les 2000 points alors vous ne
quittez pas parce qu'à 22h avec
christian bauer lui même viendra sur le
plateau
et commentera une de ces parties où
plusieurs de ces partis on verra suivant
le temps qu'on aura donc en direct en
vidéo christian bauer va commenter c'est
cette première partie et les plus
intéressantes en deuxième rang trouve
aussi un
un espoir important des échecs français
c'est laurent frayssinet qui qui est
maître international alors c'est avec
arnaud hauchard qui aussi mais bardot va
être grand maître bientôt oui laurent
aussi donc laurent frayssinet qui est un
jeune joueur qui a un peu près de là je
retiens de maquereaux je crois un an
plus un an de plus oui et qui a un très
bon pote de progression et laurent en
fait vider un petit peu quand même déçu
parce que il a fait un excellent tournoi
mais il a gaffé et de gaffer dans sa
partie contre manuela peas est là et il
a perdu en fait et a perdu une pièce
alain kouck donc c'est un peu incroyable
et évidemment c'est demi point où un
point entier ce aliments qui pourraient
être en tête ou un demi point et ça
compte beaucoup
sinon il avait joué très bien non qu'il
a fait nul contre dortmund dans une
partie où il a aussi il a montré
beaucoup de ressources parce qu'il était
en difficulté et il a réussi à sauver le
demi point
et puis il a montré beaucoup de choses
je crois qu'il est très fort lui c'est
un des candidats sérieux au titre
mais il a un point de moins que
christian bauer aujourd'hui voilà donc
laurent frayssinet à surveiller de près
aussi mais évidemment il a besoin d'un
point du leader ça va être plus dur mais
il est toujours là et on va retrouver un
troisième ex-aequo
donc sur trois ex-aequo avec quatre
points dans ce groupe b on retrouve et
yossi dortmund alors dorfman c'est un
joueur dont qui viennent des pays de
l'est c'était l'ancien entraîneur de
garry kasparov tout il a été champion de
france il ya deux ou trois ans à méribel
en 98 voilà c'est ça donc c'est un des
joueurs qu'ils relèvent le niveau des
élèves français par son niveau
intrinsèque déjà par sa propre force de
jeu et aussi parce qu'il donne des cours
il a donné beaucoup de cours et
notamment aussi à etienne bacrot bull
était son entraîneur
oui il a été l'entraîneur détiennent
macro il a fait certainement beaucoup de
bien il a aussi entraîné l'équipe de
france avant les olympiades de novi sad
80 92
et puis il entraîne beaucoup de joueurs
c'est d'un entraîneur très très fort
donc il a une compréhension des échecs
très grande mais les échecs sont un
sport en espagne nous savons depuis un
certain temps donc en tant que joueur il
lui manque cette gré si vite et cette
combativité et il a réussi il ay fait
six parties nulles ici et gagner une
seule partie contre guillaume valin avec
une jolie partie notamment un coup
cavaliers des quatre petites bombes
qu'il faut voir l'aspect relationnel
peut-être peut-être eloi tu peux nous
préparer pour toute à l'heure cette
partie donc de rien contre eux voilà
contre vannes 1 peut-être jeu palois si
tu m'entends
pour vous préparer la partie hors pointe
contre vannes 1 où il ya un coup qu'avec
des quatre comme peut-être pouvoir
commenter à la fin de ce tour d'horizon
des joueurs alors on va passer ensuite
au quatrième joueur à la c c'est un
joueur tout à fait atypique je pense que
les amateurs c'est l'amateur aulas a je
crois que c'est le plus fort amateurs de
france puisqu'il n'est pas professionnel
il est je crois un ingénieur dans une
société qui fait d'eux
j'ai travaillé sur le son je crois et
c'est le maître international jean rené
corps qu'elle largement le niveau d'un
grand maître et qui depuis très
longtemps fait parler de lui la
génération de joël lautier mais il a
choisi lui de paf en faire son métier
voilà donc ça fait plaisir de les voir à
ce niveau il a joué très très bon
tournoi
la dernière randy jouer contre happy
c'est là il avait les blancs les apc la
devait gagner donc appuyé c'est la
veille en plus mais jean-rené s'est
accroché c'est une de ses
caractéristiques est souvent il a sauvé
des parties lui aussi aidé à gagner sa
place
il vise la norme de grand maître qui lui
donnerait le titre
pour l'instant je crois qu'il doit avoir
une performance de 2560 3,6 me souvenir
exactement oui et donc il va s'il marque
un point sur deux parce qu'il va jouer
comme touba crocs il va il est tout
proche de la norme de grand maître
voilà donc jean rony corps qui est donc
en bonne position pour faire un nombre
de grands maîtres
alors c c'est le dernier qualifié donc
pour cette poule e hôte donc avec le
groupe ea on va retrouver donc hochart
nataf paquereau deux graves du groupe a
et donc bauer freyssinet dorfman décor
du groupe b et ensuite on va trouver
donc on finit le tour d'horizon des
joueurs du national
le grand maître manuela peas est là qui
est lui aussi de la génération de gens
en écosse
c'est à peu près le même âge et donc il
fait un bon tournoi aussi mais il rate
la qualification d'un demi point donc
une performance un peu supérieure à ce
montant pour lui alors ensuite on trouve
notre joueur des ex pays de l'est
alors qu'elle peut être un peu passé
niveau parce qu'ils se consacrent un peu
moins aux échecs actuellement d'affairé
là c'est anatolie valserres et qui est
très fort et un très fort il est très
fort mais donc lui c'est un petit peu il
a un style qui n'est pas du tout celui
de youssef d'hormones c'est un
combattant de l'échiquier et
là le fait de ne pas jouer deux tournois
de haut niveau ça le handicap énormément
et donc ici il a été un petit peu en
dessous et donc qu'il a perdu une partie
quand guillaume valin qu'il a dès le
début qui lui a enlevé tout espoir alors
ensuite on trouve encore un jeune joueur
alors qu'elle à gildas robert fontaine
et nationale il est tout jeune
c'est notre champion de france junior
voilà donc y laisser son point de vue
niort il joue chez les grands en fait
tout à fait la 62e nationale il l'a fait
le national 97 à narbonne où il était
déjà champion de france junior et là il
avait énormément souffert
il avait terminé dernier mais surtout en
inde est parti très très difficile
par contre dans ce tournoi il s'est
assez bien comporté et donc il a
nettement progressé en force de je vous
rappelle que robert fontaine avait
disputé un match de beach contre lui
bergez sur diagonale d'ailleurs qu'on
avait retransmis en direct qui est
disponible toujours donc vous pouvez
voir ce match de blitz entre luc bergez
et robert fontaine qui a dû se dérouler
mois de mai ou juin
donc je j'y pense parce que le maître
luc berger c'est justement là je crois
qu'ils jouent l'accession et je
l'accession il est parmi les dix sept
maîtres internationaux de l'accession
qui rêve d'une qualification pour le
national mais sûrement pas raison et on
retrouve donc le dernier de cette poule
il fait lui aussi un point et demi comme
comme laurent guitare et lee
c'est le qualifie de l'accession de l'an
dernier donc là aussi un jour mon titre
et guillaume vallet donc fait partie de
ces joueurs qui l'on donne la
possibilité de jouer ce national tu as
fait donc c'est un an titré mais on
pressent que maître international en
tout cas il a réalisé deux normes de
maître international
la deuxième c'était à bagneux en juillet
et puis à créon
il a fait une performance qui aura
peut-être valeur de de normes de mettre
en fait il lui manque un joueur étranger
puisque pour faire une norme
il faut qu'il y ait un quota minimum de
quatre étrangers sur sur les dix joueurs
et là il en avait que trois donc
c'est pas tout à fait énorme et ça peut
passer donc devant la commission donc il
sera peut-être maître international mais
de toute façon il a le niveau et il va
devenir maître international très vite
il n'y a pas de problème alors voilà
donc on a fait le tour de l'ensemble des
joueurs du national on va parler un
petit peu donc des autres tournois on a
parlé de l'accession on a parlé un peu
des joueurs de de l'accession donc ce
tournoi qui qualifie pour l'an prochain
pour le national on va voir un peu du
national féminin
je crois que les nationaux féminins
jamais été aussi fort effectivement il
ya plein joueuses jeudi à plus de 2200
points ce qui n'est pas habituel chez
les féminines puisque en général les
meilleures féminines étaient il ya
quelques années encore à 2000 points
oui donc pour faire progresser le niveau
des échecs criminels français ya
plusieurs méthodes ont d'une part les
joueuses qui progresse d'autre part de
jeunes joueuses qui arrivent
et puis troisièmement il ya une
troisième voie il ya des joueurs qui
épousent des ges des pays de l'est
nous devons y en a un certain nombre qui
deviennent française donkey à marjah les
comptes il y à un rose à la demande et
il y à marina costagliola il y à marina
roumégous on a quatre joueuses qui ont
été naturalisées françaises après avoir
épousé un français un joueur d'échecs
français et qui font qu'ils font que le
niveau est très relevé
mais surprise dans ce féminin parce que
bon tous les pronostics sont renversés
dès la première ronde mal et les
favorites qui était quand même donc
d'une part maria le compte d'autre part
aux à l'allemand les deux plus forts et
l'eau 2289 plus christine f lire et une
france deux fois champion de france
les deux dernières années et donc ces
trois étaient ont été rapidement battu
et on se retrouve
très mal hors course par contre marina
costagliola fait un sans faute elle a
six points sur six donc c'était en
réalité un extraordinaire donc on va pas
qui va l'arrêter maintenant en fait deux
joueuses les deux joueuses qui sont
derrière en quatre points et demi
il s'agit de marie ce bug alors ils se
font parler parce que c'est toute l'âme
ces vagues c'est là un petit peu les
tiennes va confirmer on va dire chez les
filles c'est la fille qui marche le
mieux c'est la plus jeune a été champion
de france je crois chez les garçons est
là elle est championne de france des
moins de 14 ans toutes catégories toutes
catégories donc chez les garçons en fait
cela parce que les fils du vent
et puis elle est championne d'europe des
moins de 14 ans donc c'est un espoir on
peut dire que c'est un espion et des
félins de monter le niveau est d'arriver
à un bon niveau à un très fort niveau de
jeu bon il fera plaie que dans
nationales telles par exemple elle a
fait nul contre gilles miralles nuls
contre laurent frayssinet en partie qui
comptait donc des parties très
importante donc où les grands mais ne
les ont pas fait de cadeau
je crois aussi en partie rapide elle
avait battu eloi et lorlanges alors on
va on va faire une petite interruption
parce qu'on a avec nous il va arriver
tout de suite c'est le grand maître
international marc santoro mans l'autre
tu peux venir marty de blé champion de
france 90 91 et 94
voilà donc bon soir marc micro alors
mars un tourment
tu joue actuellement le tournoi
accession alors comment ça se passe
est-ce que c'est difficile d'essayer de
remonter en fait puisque tu vas essayer
de te qualifier pour le national mais
l'ancien première fois que je vous
retourne l'accession j'ai toujours eu la
chance de voir jouer elle assuré que
j'ai désiré parce que j'avais à l'époque
un niveau suffisant même quand j'étais
très jeune et je me suis dit tiens on va
faire un challenge va se faire un défi
on va voir si on est capable de gagner
ce tour loin et s'est passé c'est pas
facile parce qu'il faut faire beaucoup
de points
il faut faire beaucoup de points il faut
pas un n'a pas beaucoup de droit à
l'erreur à mâcher déjà fauté une fois
j'ai perdu une partie des gens et là je
suis dans un groupe
le groupe de code poids demi sur six es1
quelques joueurs devant et c'est pas
facile mais quels sont les joueurs qui
dominent notamment accession le premier
ses joueurs roumaine qui habite un poste
quelques années sa peine le coup et
ensuite il ya cinq joueurs alors c'est
toujours ainsi qualifié pour le pour le
national je ne pense pas non il n'a pas
la nationalité française dont qui il a
le droit de jouer parce qu'il réside en
france depuis deux ans il est lisse il
est sur la liste fille dé france mais
par contre il ne peut pas se qualifier
pour le national alors pourquoi il s'est
sûrement là et pas un autre tournoi
plutôt parce que c'est intéressant c'est
maintenant il ya des prix intéressants
et donc d'accord donc c'est pas
uniquement 1 3
pour ce cas j'ai préféré ça peut aussi
jouer par des étrangers qui ont envie de
jouer
des trous intéressante à sion et
étrangers qui sont quand même assimilé
dans la mesure où ils vivent en france
depuis au moins deux ans ils sont 10 ans
hier la fédération depuis au moins deux
ans et en plus ils sont sur la liste
fille dé france avec le code france
d'accord dont il ya des restrictions
quand même d'accord donc un accession
difficile jean-claude loubatière des
états leur il ya beaucoup de joueurs
titrés dans ce tournoi accession cette
année c'est la première fois qu'il ya
autant il ya énormément de grands
maîtres et de mètres et beaucoup
d'anciens champions de france il serait
je pense qu'effectivement le niveau
monte de plus en plus et feytiat
peut-être qu'il y aura beaucoup plus de
gras m ans et qui sont obligés de jouer
l'accession va obliger peut-être enfin
puisque déjà on a presque une vingtaine
de grands maîtres emprunt ce matin et
comme n'ya que ça se passe le national
il restera donc des grands maîtres qui
se resterait sur le carreau qui trompait
tous à l'exception donc alors quels sont
les joueurs français donc du coup alors
qu'ils peuvent prétendre à se qualifier
pour le national de l'an prochain les
joueurs en tête français actuellement il
ya un jeune cheval qui a déjà fait
nationale et à jean pierre boudreau qui
l'a déjà fait aussi il ya olivier
touzanne qui l'a fait aussi et quelques
années et je crois je sais pas si
beaucoup d'autres choix parce que pas
mal de joueurs qui ont lâché qu'elle
déjà des poèmes parmi les favoris du
tournoi
d'accord alors on va revenir maintenant
donc on a parlé du national féminin avec
donc
marie sebag notamment la petite
française qui fait parler d'elle et puis
que les pronostics sont peu renversé
dans ce championnat il ya aussi faut
citer anne muller qui a quatre points et
demi et qui donc deuxièmes ex-aequo avec
marie et c'est aussi donc une surprise
d'accord alors on va parler aussi de
maintenant des autres tournois donc pour
moi que pour les cités parce qu'il ya
c'est un rendez vous donc à la fois très
fort pour le tournoi de importants comme
on vient de le voir l'accession qui
permet de se qualifier pour le national
le national avec avec 16 joueurs et on
va retrouver aussi d'autres tournois
ouverts aux amateurs qui fait qu' il s'
est un événement échiquéen où il ya près
de 1000 joueurs une gigantesque kermesse
où tout le monde peut venir et prendre
son plaisir
alors quelles sont ces autres tournois
une condition pour y jouer finalement
l'opéra l'opéra c'est un tournoi qui est
réservé aux jeunes qui ont entre 1900 et
2002 a relevé la barre de la peña qui
était à 18 cents l'an passé on l'a
relevé parce que le niveau augmente et
qu'ils qualifient des joueurs pour
l'accession les dix premiers sont
qualifiés pour l'accession et combien de
joueurs dans cet open à elle vient de
160 et 12 joueurs peut-être ou peut-être
même plus
donc en fait le niveau et aux 118
voilà la pomme affiche alors après donc
ça donc ça c'est le joueur plus de 2 me
de pal à 1900 points donc c'est déjà ses
formes parce que je veux que la moyenne
des lots français c'est aux alentours de
1600 points c'est ça on est mais il faut
dire que le championnat
est très forte la moyenne des 10 944
participants et 1875 c'est incroyable
mais il est logique mais faut pas
décourager les gens qui ont un niveau
moindre
on peut on peut jouer dans tous les
tournois là encore le cas mambé et puis
l'open c'est alors voilà donc il faut
faut pas avoir peur de venir jouer le
championnat de france parce que si on
dit que c'est trop fort personnes devant
venir alors mais les gens viennent aussi
pour le spectacle le national c'est un
spectacle et on n'a pas encore parlé
mais bon voir les joueurs sur la scène
avec les huit partis qui sont
retransmises en direct ont froid dès 18h
sur l'écran sur les écrans c'est
fabuleux
on fera des amateurs et puis les grands
maîtres marque centre romain y compris
bien de voir et analyser les
participants on va on va voir ça tout à
l'heure avec la partie dont on a parlé
puis on en verra d'autres avec avec
jean-marc degraeve est écrit sans bruit
évidemment on fera des images de ce
national pour montrer évidemment le
spectacle que c'est parce que c'est
évidemment important donc l'oplb
maintenant pour les moines de 2000 mouël
des moins de 2000 tout le monde peut
jouer moins de 2000 donc alors ses
réserves au moins 2000 donc si on a plus
de 2000 on peut pas s'inscrire pour ce
pour ce moment là il ya deux cent douze
joueurs c'est pas mal bien sûr et puis
donc là aussi il ya des joueurs il ya un
joueur qui à 2000 il pourrait faire il
aurait pu jouer l'open a donc puisqu'il
ya une fourchette dans lesquels on a le
choix entre l'open à et le pnb mais il a
choisi de jouer l'open b pour le gagner
pour le gagner est ce qu'il est en tête
actuellement je le vois pas dans les
produits kraft qui est en tête n'ont
donc il s'est trouvé avec les plus
petits mais il s'est fait manger oui ça
arrive donc loupé une belle réservée au
moins de 2000 et l'eau et enfin l'open
c'est réservé au moins 2700 là aussi
c'est certain nombre de joueurs comme en
2007 donc là on peut dire que c'est
réservé
on peut dire aux amateurs ouvert aux
ados tout à fait donc la sq au moins
2700 la moyenne des joueurs d'échecs de
clubs ses 1600 points à peu près tout à
fait dans beaucoup de joueurs peuvent
participer à tous les niveaux qui sont
là les gens jouent vraiment aussi pour
le plaisir marc tu peux pas jouer l'open
ses voisins le temps et j'aimerais bien
jouer l'open c gepa tremplin donc voilà
il ya près il ya un tournoi spécial
aussi qui est l'open des vétérans
championne de france des vétérans
réservé aux joueurs qui ont plus de 55
ans au 1er janvier et qui qui en est un
qui a eu un vainqueur unique depuis
trois ans et volodia vaïsman maître
international qui qui domine quand il à
200 points elo de plus que son suivant
et il a pour l'instant carton plein
dacourt donc mais par contre est ce
qu'il ya des jours de plus de 55 ans
quand ils font le national
directement est-ce qu'il y en a eu de la
nationale non mais il y en a qui jouent
dans l'open en tout cas d'accord donc en
tout cas c'est réservé si on veut jouer
avant les gens de son âge on peut jouer
aussi cet open désaltérant part ça c'est
la force des échecs aussi on peut dire
c'est qu'on peut jouer de quatre ans
jusqu'à plus soif
on n'a pas de limites dix ans que la
force de jeu aux échecs diminue un petit
peu moins vite que dans les autres
sports qu'un c'est un avantage
oui alors on a fait le tour de ses
tourments alors maintenant on va essayer
de voir justement on a parlé tout à
l'heure de cette partie entre entre rios
6 dorfman et et guillaume vallet c'est
ça aussi de devoir un petit peu cette
partie à ce que tu l'a suivi et marque
un tournant cette partie guillaume pley
je n'ai pas suivi je jouais de tournois
qui sont donc doit quand même à regarder
un peu avec nous parce qu'il paraît
qu'il ya un super coup d'état de noi
cité
alors voilà c'est cette partie
qu'on va peut-être déroulé peut-être
eloi relance que oman est là ça nous
fait dérouler les coûts des coûts de
cette de cette partie donc c'est une
défense
comment ça s'appelle ça c'est west end à
usage unique et le you steve norman joue
le coup eux 2 4 qui est donc une
surprise puisque c'est habituel dans
cette position normalement on préfère
cavaliers f3 ou vous g3 au faou g5 enfin
prend principalement fou g5 et le coût
principal e 4 c'est une surprise c'est
très ambitieux ça veut prendre
directement le centre
donc tout le centre voit trois pions au
centre qui sont quand même très très
optimiste
cette défense il mise aussi sur la
commandite plusieurs fois dans le
diagonal on a eu l'occasion
on a commenté plusieurs notamment des
fins joué par anatoli karpov contre
ajoute paul gars si je me souviens bien
donc une défense très très utilisé donc
dont le but en général marc je crois tu
me démentira pas et de contrôler la case
e 4 pour les noirs
ah oui mais oui le four et le pouce et 8
a fait le feq et aux dames et d'un a
pour objet de mettre le foin donc mais
cette et de contribuer à la casse de
cote ainsi que le cavaliere 6 voilà donc
le but voit noir c'est de contrôler
cette case et le fou en b4 cloud
lecavalier c3 qui protègent cette case
aussi donc voilà l'idée de ce coup
l'idée de cette ouverture donc c'est
pour ça que le coût de 4 et est risqué
pour les blancs puisque les noms a
priori contrôle bien ce point alors
fougue et cette très logique et la
iossif dorfman donc défend le pion aux
quatre par le coup food et trois au 6e
coup et là guillaume valin je vous
prends ses 310 être contraint puisque à
3 n'a pas encore été joué donc de france
et roi est interdite puisque le pion aux
quatre seraient en prison qui oscille
dorfman reprend du plan b et la guimauve
à linge ou des six bons ici les blancs
ont effectivement pris le centre très
fortement donc le plan des noirs je
pense que c'est bloqué la position par
ces 5 ou 5 alors peut-être que marx en
tournant que nous en dire plus puisqu'il
est c'est un joueur très positionnelle
il est trés positionné mais c'est pas
vraiment spécialité effectivement étant
donné que
les noirs inchangé leur fou noir ils
veulent essayer de contrôler classement
avec leurs pions en essayant de bloquer
la structure blanche c2 c3 par exemple
c3 c4 et le plan c 3 50 mètres 1 puis
c'est sympa on l'aura m pour rendre donc
le fou le foot dès le fond blanc des
blancs un peu inutile quoi souffrent des
trois qui débuterait canton ses propres
pions en fait c'est simplement voilà
idée alors cavaliers j'ai eu deux
périodes mais même puisque c'est le sol
damas est petit rock les blancs sortent
leurs pièces et maintenant effectivement
les noirs ont un problème puisqu'ils
savent plus trop quoi faire de leurs
droits sur petit rock qui vont se faire
proprement pulvérisé puisque iossif
dorfman aura joué avec f4 f5 ou f4 5 fu
des trois dames c'est lui enfin les deux
sont braqués sur le roi dont guillaume
valin choisi jouer à gran rock mais on
va voir que c'est pas beaucoup mieux
qu'elle et ses six dont grand roc
s'avère un rop du côté donc dame
on va voir ses seins l'europe si le
moins usité mais qui n'en est pas moins
efficace fou à 3 donc clouage sur la
dame hausse est là comme on peut le voir
effectivement donc la dame le pion des
six ne peut pas bouger puisque le fou
prendrait la dame d'amd cette f4 iossif
prend tout le centre grand roque des 5
voilà c'est le coup clé dans cette
position il chasse le cavalier le
cavalier va très logiquement à 5
et maintenant après fourbe et 4 c'est
une catastrophe pour les noirs
puisqu'ils peuvent plus éviter fou prend
cavaliers qui affaiblit complètement la
structure de pions côté grand roc noir
et après ça la défense devient très très
difficiles notamment que le cavaly blanc
aux deux peuvent sauter en t4
probablement
alors donc ça veut dire aussi que si une
fois que les blancs en prendront ce
cavalier à 5 donc que le pion b6 va
reprendre savoir une colonne pour les
blancs qui est la colonne b une tour
blanche donc pourra se positionner avec
une grosse attaque
sur le foot bessette et en plus sur le
roi noir voilà donc ici guillaume va
linge ou c5
il y aussi je prends à 5 très logique b
prend à tour à b1
on comprend la colonne mais bon ça pas
l'impression que la marque sans tourment
que les que les noirs ont pas de
contrôle de la laub posées aux blancs
mais le problème du plan des noirs c'est
le problème active leur tour et je l'aï
donc pas de d'avenir pour leur prison
pas la capacité vraiment d'ouvrir une
colonne balises avaient ils ont juste
prendre des 5 c'est prendre les singles
c'est pas bon pour eux quoi donc ils ont
gain contre je veux donc qu'ils sont
c'est juste une question de temps
maintenant pour pour gagner pour les
blancs de caution qu'on peut noter la
différence d'activité entre la tour b 1
qui contrôle cette colombe et si on peut
montrer sa 17e cette colonne déjà merci
excellent et loire et le noir par contre
n'ont pas l'équivalent puisque leurs
deux tours en des 8 es une fille qu'on
le fait remarquer marc ce roman sont
mais finalement derrière leurs pions et
donc ne participe à l'action pour
l'instant le faux b71 +21 est vraiment
passif était bon nous allons peut-être
passé sur cette partie puisque d'autres
attendent quand même un autre invité à
temps on va peut-être arriver aux coups
que vous les montrer jean-claude
loubatière juste après puisque les
blancs ont joué le pressage et 1004 ce
cavalier des quatre la superbe coup 16e
coup le fameux 16e cookies dans ce
tournant est critique puisque arnaud
hauchard battu des records et nietzsche
ans et ce coup il ya eu plusieurs 16e
coup très critique dans cet endroit et
l'accueil et des quatre en est un
effectivement sur ces prend des quatre
je pense qu'il suivrait une combinaison
alors voyez si les noirs prennent le
cavalier des quatre qu'est-ce qui se
passe donc jean claude besse skis bien
il joue ses 5 ce qui s'est passé là pour
avoir la bonne affluence évidemment des
filtres et cavaliers dans le camp
adverse
suppose en c6 ou en b 5 et noir prennent
le cavalier c'est la partie donc nous
disons que le bâtir dont on peut voir tu
comprends bien c'est 5 c5 et la c5 et sa
démoli complètement le camp noir c'est à
dire que c'est un affront pour 1,6 en
fait ça me laisse vous prend à 6 et
après ah oui la baignoire et charge les
noirs sont obligés dé changer le foot
est roi et à près d'un mètre en d3 il ya
un adage de maths c'est ça ainsi menacer
damas six échecs et mat il pratiquement
matt black guillaume valant essaie de
sortir il ajouté à ma 4 mais aussi le
tough man ne laisse pas le roi
s'échapper en dix-sept il joue c5 c6
haoussa ans ferme laurent noir
complètement c'est très beau en ferme
non loin de 20 effectivement après tour
de18 pour aller sur la case des huit
dames à 6 échec au roi des 8 et là on
enferme le roi une dernière fois avec
d'un point à 7
hélas la menace tour b8 mater est
totalement imparable donc que thief
dorfman une pièce de moins mais une
position quand même gagnante puisque il
a gagné très très jolie partie de demain
alors je vous rappel vous pouvez
télécharger les partis de tous ceux
nationale donc revoir la partie
entièrement à votre rythme avec les
commentaires donc lacombe d'avoir de
jean-claude loubatière et marque son
retour au mans vous pouvez voir ces
partis en téléchargeant les parties donc
sur le site de la fédération verra plus
la fédération www poèmes échec au
pluriel point asso.fr voilà il a on a
toutes les parties télécharger en format
pg n est qu un format qui est visible
par tous les logiciels du marché quand
on peut dire et aussi des logiciels
libres en téléchargement gratuit sur
internet tout est là mais je vous
remercie tous les deux de nous avoir
accompagnés ces quelques minutes et on
va recevoir de nouveaux invités
et non des moindres puisque c'est tout
joueur de la poule donc à du national
c'est il me rejoignent maintenant donc
jean-marc degraeve bonsoir jean marc le
grand maître international jean-marc
degraeve bonsoir et donc laurent guitare
et lee dont on a parlé de ça leur est
donc c'est un des joueurs qui s'est
qualifiée pour nationale en gagnant de
l'accession l'année dernière enfin ça
alors jean marc
on a parlé de toi tout à l'heure parce
que tu as fait une très bonne
performance hier tu as battu le champion
de france 99
oui bon je devais presque gagné mais bon
s'il faisait nul j'étais en fait c'est
un match des partages avec jean marc
siano
donc je devais à tout prix gagner mon
jeu joue un début que je connaissais
très bien j'avais les blancs ça a bien
marché
la hiérarchie est un peu modeste parce
que c'est pas c'est pas tous les jours
que tu y être macro permet une partie
oui l'année passée l'a perdu la dernière
aussi la septième est donc peut-être
qu'il perd tout laisser tuer monde je
sais pas quand tout était arrangé pour
jouer la 7e voilà alors laurent et
toutes armées dit c'est intéressant
d'avoir un joueur comme ça qu'ils
viennent l'accession dernière quel effet
ça fait de jouer entre 10 mai parmi les
grands on peut dire ça d'abord c'est
vachement impressionnant quoi parce que
enfin je vends n'ont pas l'habitude de
jouer contre des joueurs de ce niveau
c'est la première fois que que jon
tourna aussi fort et puis il faut dire
que la première ronde c'était assez
impressionnant de jouer devant un public
aussi nombreux quoi donc c'est très
impressionnant ça déstabilise peu ouais
on a les mains qui tremblent un peu
paumé bon bout d'un moment après ça va
s'habituer
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on a le sentiment
de progresser on a apprécié cette
première ronde aux joueurs qu'on a
rencontrés - f1 c'est clair que
tous les jours on apprend et surtout à
l'analyse gm fonctionne d'avoir donc la
dame a pris beaucoup de choses on va
rappeler ce que c'est l'analyse alors
certes les joueurs il faut qu'on
explique un peu ce qui se passe
les joueurs après leur parti donc on se
retrouve dans une salle à côté et
revoient leur parti qui s'explique les
coups qu'ils ont ratées ou qu'ils
auraient voulu jouer on compare un petit
peu ce qu'on a vu en un cliché sein
pendant la partie et on essaie de
trouver de nouvelles idées ou
d'améliorer celles qu'on a eu pendant la
partie de voir si on peut essayer de
voir à quel endroit on a fait une fois
ci on a perdu ou quelque chose comme ça
et essayer d'améliorer avec ça avec son
adversaire notre jeu alors justement
profité d'avoir deux jours du national
encore une fois pour commenter des
partis parce que ça va être très
intéressant
alors je prends envoyé de commenter
peut-être votre parti entre tous les
deux sont certes intéressants comme ça
d'avoir le la vie de du vainqueur qui a
été donc jean-marc admis la partie 1
féminine ah bon pardon je crois que
c'était la partie jeu réduit les excuses
ont donc assez une partie nulle qui a
duré comme un coût 35 36 56 a fini par
un échec perpétuerait l'ont donc du
cirque perpétuelle qui peut rappeler ce
que c'est jean-marc donc en fait il lui
il fait échec à chaque fois mon roi mon
juana ne peut pas il est obligé de
bouger sans la même case
en fait on répète on est obligé de
répéter plusieurs fois la même position
que moi donc on va on va voir cette
partie
donc entre jean-marc degraeve et nos
plans guides harry donc pas gagné mais
nulle part dont je pense que c'est une
partie
e
donc laurent tu as réussi à faire trois
parties nulles sur les sur les toutes
les parties qui doit opposer si c'est
difficile d'approcher des points ses
joueurs - ouais très difficile à chaque
fois l'objet de de m'accrocher vraiment
de faire la partie de ma vie tous les
jours il faut répéter ça et c'est un
moment très difficile donc la sergente
italie oui en plus je pense qu'elle est
allée assez intéressante à regarder
voilà cette partie on voit tout de suite
notre jamar de travail qui dure donc 35
coups donc on va essayer de commenter
les goûts et l ouverture pour les gens
qui nous écoutent c'est intéressant
alors si on peut commencer à voir les
premiers coups oui alors on peut on peut
commencer donc jean-marc degraeve avec
les blancs jouent à 4 comme d'habitude
je dirais puisqu'il joue pratiquement
exclusivement secoue ses cinq cavaliers
f3 des six alors ça tout de suite en
deux tendances assez une défense il
yal'un contredisez pas mais oui c'est
une défense sicilienne et mon après des
six normalement on tourne peut-être vers
une âge d'or ce que je vous kasparov
d'ailleurs ce que je vaux kasparov alors
on va voir
alors voyons ça d4 et la kabylie et 6 un
peu atypique normalement on prend des
caps d'abord on élimine tout de suite
l'ambiance est donc c'est alors c'est
atypique
c'est intéressant parce qu'on a le rang
avec nous oui pourquoi ce coup d'abord
en fait habituellement jamin que je vous
ces trois autres c4 d'ailleurs il ya un
an ou deux mais je fous c4 est là comme
il a joué des cats j'ai pensé qu'ils
voulaient jouer autre chose qui s'était
préparé et j'ai imaginé qu'ils voulaient
jouer dans 30 des quatre sur ces 30 des
4 et ensuite jouer en ligne avec ses 4
et comme j'aimais pas vraiment ça je
voulais éviter ça je joue d'abord
cavaliers f6 et maintenant si je joue
cavalier ces trois lots qui ont ses deux
propres venir en c4 et donc j'ai réussi
plus ou moins évité sa préparation je
pense
voilà l'explication
c'est bon on attend donc la donc
effectivement j'ai un âge où kbc 3 pour
protéger la 4c le couple naturel
jean-marc oui on peut on peut aussi
prendre dans ses 5 alors que en train dé
4 ensuite d'emprunter 4 quand même alors
dans ça c'était le leem que tu voulais
vite et je voulais éviter la ligne avec
des refrains des quatre essais 4 donc là
il a un cavalier c3 je trouvais ça un
petit peu moins désagréable quoi
d'accord donc la lada est exposée quand
même au pied adverse puisque le coup
cavalli c6 va être obligé de la chasse
et ça va gagner un temps pour les noirs
oui mais je voulais pas jouer tout de
suite parce que je pense que jean marc
coma répondre du fou b5 et je
préférerais éviter en faisant d'abord
fou 17 et éviter le clouage avec footing
d'accord donc la loro pardon les lois
nous montre admirablement ce qui se
serait passé
donc la foux 17 donc ensuite l'allée
blanc réplique par un malware tout de
suite ou gsm donc ça on rentre c'est des
schémas de la nage des enfants n'ont
maintenant c'est un peu changé parce que
mon la nage des enfants jouent avec à 6
donc bon il est blanc en plus dans la
jungle âge d'enfants jouant cavalier f3
prend des 4 donc on leur cavalier f3 en
déca tepa la dame quoi ce qui est mieux
quand donc ces gens pareils oui en fait
non c'est on a vu tout ce qui est c'est
6 de nationale alors que six dont classe
et on a quand même une structure de
sicilienne avec les noirs la différence
près que il semblerait que l'on ait
perdu beaucoup de temps qu'on parviendra
aux heures normales ou de cavaliers
serait déjà en d4 je pense oui c'est
donc sa porte donc ici après aussi je
pense que les bleus ont perdu un temps
je ne sais pas jean-marc comment tu te
sens tu es dans cette position mais en
tout cas a priori il semblerait que les
noirs et effet un succès avec cette
ouverture mais j'étais pas très content
j'avoue notera donc c'est un succès
puisque laurent c'est donc un succès
d'ouverture pour les noirs
oui je n'ose y succès en tant qu'homme
oui j'avais je pense plus ou moins
deviner que j'en m'en voulais jouer avec
d'emprunt des quatre essais 4 et en
jouant cavalier fils d'abord je pense
que jouer damon en 2004 par la suite
c'était pas très pas la meilleure idée
peut-être mais si jean-marc avait
préparé ça l'est peut-être pas regarder
d'autres choses après qu'elle ait emmené
quatre d'accord donc là on a fait donc
le grand roque de la part des blancs ce
qui paraît logique puisque le terrain
été déblayés puis maintenant la tour est
bien placé sur une colonne centrale à
six et maintenant cavalier des 4 donc ça
fait internet de moins c'est pas c'est
pas du tout une bonne opération pour les
blancs a priori est ici les noirs
continue logiquement par fos est donc
position assez tranquille le roi noir va
faire le petit rock et va être à l'abri
donc ici c'est une c est normal avec
peut-être l'égalité probable pour les
noix donc ça ressemble cette fois
maintenant jean-marc un âge d'or mais
plutôt une ryder comme une culture à
auzat et c'est un peu pressé
l'opposition vais rentrer à ce niveau là
parce que voici s'était joué à dix ans
qu'une quelquefois dans le dans la nage
dorff on joue plutôt 5
on met le pion aux sept ans rue 5
d'accord donc bon là on a plutôt joué
aussi donc on retourne dans des plus tôt
dans des schémas draps aux heures on est
des 6 e 6 tandis que tant la nage coffre
khalfan même plan que 5
une autre différence effectivement c'est
que le cavalier souvent dans la neige
dorff ne va pas ans et 6 mai en 17 et
ans et 5 pour attaquer puis en quatre à
mettre la pression sur les cases
blanches
enfin disons qu'on n'a pas encore sorti
de calais débitons garde plus de
souplesse un jeune âge d'or
de très fort mais nous explique tout ça
donc c'est très bien aussi j'apprends
comme vous donc là on est à cavalier
prend des cartes pour les noirs et voilà
les bleus reprennent le travail et ce
qui paraît logique
et demain c'est pour ça c'est un bout de
développement de la dame oui oui on
attaque le fouquet si tu as un g5 et
d'un style de position dans la
sicilienne est généralement les les
rucks on deux côtés opposés donc les
blancs ont essayé d'attaquer sur les
droits et les noms plutôt sur les ailes
dame
donc je peux je positionne léger madone
du coût d'un endroit john oui on a 5
parce que le pion à deux cas assez
faible 1 dans le grand roque
c'est le point faible souvent donc mon
cavalli c3 ne peut pas bouger quoi
d'accord dont peut-être les blanche doit
faire attention à pousser le pnb 4/10
chasserait lecavalier
alors ensuite
donc on va voir la suite d'un des deux
donc ici ça bon pour l'instant on n'a
simplement retiré la dame
oui mais mon idée c'était un peu de
jouer donc de protéger le fou j'ai cinq
blessures et sur petit rock de jouets 3
p1 afin de pouvoir menacer cavaliers des
cinq classiques après roy bien qu'à
valider cinq évidemment là d'un des deux
reprises mais s'il a d'abord le prend on
prend d'abord le phone 7 avec l'échec et
ensuite on va ensuite on reprend la
demande la gagnante s
oui tout à fait donc ça c'est
effectivement c'est un des thèmes c'est
un piège classique oui mais bon la dame
est mieux pressants des deux camps les
quatre coins donc j'en profite un ventre
anodine selon m
cette dame ça fait 2 elle s'affine
deuxième fois que l'un des quatre il
revient
donc l'impression qu'il perd du temps à
y perdre du temps mais c'est la vie pour
ses victoires ses huit de la part des
non ça c'est toujours dans l'idée
d'attaquer de tolède armes oui toujours
wayne et on garde toujours à l'esprit un
des thèmes classiques de la cécilienne
qui est de sacchi sacrifier la qualité
en c3 pour pouvoir affaiblir leur rock
adverse et là en l'occurrence en même
temps on voit qu'une fois que le
cavaliere a été pris on pourra jouer est
en train de continuer la tacc d'accord
donc c'est très logique
et pourquoi retarder l'europe est ce
qu'on dit toujours il faut rauque et
vite alors en fait j'essaie et tirer
profit du fait que jean marc avait perdu
plusieurs temps comme on vient de le
dire est que saddam notamment et donc je
me disais que peut-être qu'il fallait
que je lance une attaque très rapidement
alors que lui n'avait pas encore
commencé la semaine sur une perte de 2 7
à 2 une perte de temps et peut-être
comment - est pour l'instant plus
d'insécurité au centre que s'il était un
g8
d'accord on peut remarquer ici que les
noirs ou une menace immédiate même tour
en c3 est vraiment très fort puisque
d'emprunt est interdite à cause de dames
profond j'ai cinq échecs mais qui
voudrait prendre du plomb b après d'un
point à 2 les noirs serait beaucoup
mieux une variante signalé par luc
bergez tout de suite il ya une menace
dit aussi pour les noirs tout reprend
ses droits et cavaliers prend 1,4 gagne
tout de suite sur monastir france et 3b
prend ces trois cavaliers prend quatre
gagnants immédiatement oui donc une
menace vraiment très direct peut-être en
semaine on peut hélas
vous invite à analyser certainement la
menace des noirs tout reprendre
cavaliers ces trois suivants tuellement
de cavaliers prend 4 c'est ça oui c'est
ça et après fou prend g5 et je gagne la
dame d2 avec leur ont assez inquiets qui
est cloué voilà c'est clair j'ai compris
j'espère donc voilà à ce cadre pour les
pour les blancs 6 alors ça donc les les
noirs demandant fou ce qui va faire
c'est ça voila voila j'ai réfléchi à ses
20 ans ce coup parce que je comptais
jouets des cinq tout de suite mais le
fond en jeu 5 était assez gênant dans
plusieurs variantes
donc j'ai décidé d'abord de le chasser
et ensuite seulement de jouer des cinq
pour essayer d'ouvrir le jeu et attaquer
directement le roi de journée sa contre
attaque de tous les côtés donc le fou
revient sur le cas de trois et on
préfère se reculer alors est ce qui fait
d'autres solutions jamais votre nom
parce qu'on va pas donner le fou de
cases noires préfou praxis ou praxis le
fouga soir serait terrible mon cavalier
ces trois îles de voeux sera attaqué
enfin ça serait pas possible
fouad 4 le fou ne sert à rien prêter
saint cloud en escadre ne servirait
strictement rien à eux trois ils
contrent les casses b si c'est cassé 5
quelquefois ça peut être utile
voilà l'explication de jasmin de grasse
on secoue foudroie alors ensuite donc
les noirs suivent porte des 5 alors ça
c'est lors des 5
c'est souvent on le dit je crois dans
les
pas mal et puis on en a parlé dans des
gones a aussi plusieurs fois c'est dans
la sicilienne un coup libérateur voilà
et là en l'occurrence en libère la
diagonale pour le fouquet place et en
recettes et en menacent directement fou
b4 qui permettra par exemple un
sacrifice de qualité en c3 mais prend
ses trois faut prendre ces trois et les
nombreux biens tomate et le contenant
oui disons plutôt que c'est notre rating
est une pièce puisque effectivement
après foulée quatre ans et trois
gagnants gagnerait tout simplement donc
voilà l'explication donc en tout cas
désindexer du coup une grosse menace
pour toi jean-marc à ce niveau là il
faut faire attention à vos bécanes
oui il faut faire très attention mais de
façon je peux pas l'empêcher 1 donc il
faut essayer de contrecarrer ce plan
parce que c'est un moment là tu tu as
peur de perdre le contrôle de la partie
est ce que c'est ça tu es venu à
l'esprit nous sommes est venu un peu un
esprit bon jeu mais j'ai vu que mon
j'avais analysé quand même un peu des 5
parce que bon c'est le coup libérateur
donc bon c'est le coût comprend 100
premiers mois j'avais vu que c'était
compliqué mais bon moi aussi j'aime bien
les parties compliqué quoi donc c'était
une partie intéressante donc serein
quand même dans la difficulté
serein mais pas 100% tranquille non
d'accord donc la cij ou en fait hein
c'est le moment de la partie qui est
très chaud alors on a bien compris que
deux joueurs sont tendues donc le coup
eux 5 qui cherchent à bloquer peut-être
la position c'est ça je cherche à
bloquer mes bourreaux j'attaque le
cavalier 5 et je jouais en fait tu fous
des quatre qui protégera manque avait
laissé trois bons à la ligne est
d'accord donc on fixe un peu le centre
et puis on va essayer de contrôler ce
câble et c3 qui a ciblé des noirs
puisque le foufou b4 menace oui le
cavaliere 6 n'a pas beaucoup de cases
commenté ça c'est un joli coup grand
puisque tu sacrifies ton cavaliers de
six mois je veux moi j'ai envie de
prendre
notre suite comprend cavaliers oui en
fait c'est pas tout à fait un sacrifice
parce que je peux jouer tout reprendre
ces trois maintenant et je manque peut
pas reprendre la tour sous peine de
demain est assez rapide après faut
prendre ces trois et dana trois tchèques
donc sur pied pour un cavalier tour 36 3
si tu reprends alors pas de la dame
évidemment puisque tu perdais la danoise
ont mis les pions en trois il y aurait
maintenant faut prendre ces trois faut
penser 3 la dame est attaqué les îles si
la dame bouge on joue d'un à trois
échecs
rob est un et maintenant dmb demain
voilà donc c'est une attaque de maths
donc il faut faire très attention mais
j'ai un autre prend quand même le
cavalier et sa nonchalance assez la
variante que de montreuil loi c'est la
parade pour démontrer loi voilà donc qui
on prend 1,6 il y aurait tout prendre
cavaliers par exemple sur food et 4 nos
pions pranger set d'abord intermédiaire
tour g8
alors non alors on a des problèmes parce
qu'ils voient là qui vont progresser est
hors g8 dont j'imite par exemple sur un
coup comme roy b1 les noirs jouent tour
à 3 to à 3 ah oui on s'attaque la dame
d2 et la tour va prendre le pion à de
sérieux et je me faire mater et à la
native de fermeté alors il faut fait
faut éviter cet aréna
il faut éviter de se faire mater je
pense oui alors on va on va revenir
évidemment on va revenir à cette
position très intéressante donc ça
c'était et loire l'engin qui nous a
montré les coûts donc de possibles
donc après le 5-fu b4 il faut que voilà
jean marc a joué le coup foot des quatre
qui consolide win en fait bon ça arrive
souvent dans cette sicilienne
c'est qu'on sacrifie à 2 contre les
changes du fou de cases noires et comme
ça les noirs ont nettement moins d'attac
ou est ce que les noirs ont quand même
pouvoir prendre pion à deux francs
cavaliers et apprête à prendre la dame
trois hommes menaçants damas un match on
va voir que ce que justement
ce qu'a joué loin mais il a joué la
variante faut prendre cavaliers fou
prend cavaliers d'un parent à 2 et
attention puisqu'il ya menace damas même
attention
donc je peux pas prendre le cavalier
fils donc s'il est si on prenait le
cavalier aussi ça serait matin donc dans
des cartes ça sert à donner de l'air au
roi si damas un chèque roi des deux et
on s'échappe
voilà voilà donc cavalier g8 maintenant
donc les noirs repris leur travail
lorsqu'elle n'est pas une meilleure case
pour ce cavalier parce qu'en général on
n'aime pas trop remettre ces pièces sur
l'emploi c'est pas la seule case qui
restait c'était h5 mais j'aimais pas
trop mettre mon cavalier à la bande mais
surtout je pense que j'en manque serait
filmé plaisir d'essayer de me la trappe
et un joint par exemple courage 3 et g4
et lecavalier a plus de cases d'accord
donc cavalier g8
ça c'est tranquille et se dit que le
quartier va être recyclés par la part de
crs et ses six parcs voilà et après on
peut éventuellement même fait refaire la
peinture exact d'accord donc eu 5
alors non d'alger 4 pardon comme g4
alors sa menace le pion g7
oui en fait j'en manque essayer de tirer
profit du fait que mon aileron et pas
très bien développé et il essaie tout de
suite d'avoir dû contre jeu d'accord
donc là les noirs joue cavalier set
quand même donc là c'est un sacrifice de
pions oui je retiens que j'ai pris un à
deux mais d'un autre côté je vais
je vais active et mes pièces tout de
suite et les développer d'accord donc
déjà marqué prend donc en fait à chaque
fois un millier de menaces mais on le
fait quand même
c'est ça l'image si je joue l'un des
quatre et qui joue kallio set je prends
g7
sinon jouer john g can servir vraiment
rien d'accord ce n'était pas une menace
dans le vent comme on y allant d'un
match 7
alors pourquoi h7 cette dame est ce
qu'il est bien placé n'a pas tant elle
pouvait pas prendre le pion à 6 aussi on
va peut-être avancer parce que la fin de
la partie comme très intéressante oui
voilà damage 7 c'est important parce
qu'elle défend ses deux on ne verra plus
tard
alors fou à 4 maintenant un tacle
pioncer 2 justement alors j'ai quatre
voilà et si j'avais joué comme
franchissent les noirs auraient pu jouer
tout reprend ses trois mails à la dame
h7 défense et 2 dont il ya pas mal pensé
de a ha oui d'accord parce qu'après
pions principe ses droits à la dame et
le four est attaqué c'est 2 et adam
d'accord la dame h7 protège cette case
c'est donc tout le tout l'idée de jean
marc sur ce qu'on voit là et en plus ce
qui a valu à cette ne peut pas bouger
parce que la tour g8 est attaqué et oui
c'est le cabinet vous entourent g8 avec
échec perd une tournette donc le
cavalier vie c'est donc pour g6 alors
davantage c'est quoi laurent c'est une
idée oui et en même temps je coupe la
diagonale dame verser 2 donc habitants
menacent à nouveau tout reprendre ces
trois cas les mêmes idées que tout à
l'heure
voilà donc tout l'intérêt on protège la
tour par un pion et donc plus par le
cavalier et ensuite on menace tout
reprendre fou avec menaces de mort
donc c'est chaud quand même tendu donc
vous des trois c'est intéressant
vraiment puis ça protège ses deux fils
après chaque attaque la tour une barre à
ce moment là je pense gagner la partie
parce qu'en plus il lui restait très peu
de temps je pensais qu'elle ait craqué
oui ici il semblerait quand même que les
blancs soit soit nettement mieux puisque
le roi blanc va aller en sécurité sur la
caisse d2 et les le renoir est restée au
centre tout ça s'annonce assez important
donc le temps
tu parlais du temps jean marc donc il
reste très peu de temps au blanc au noir
ou noir pardon il reste qu en fait il
doit rester
je pense de 30 me on est de 3 minutes et
une bonne dizaine de conte donc trois
minutes pour atteindre le 40e 50e
on est à quelques couleurs à peu près de
la partie je suis c'est pas du tout
peut-être eloi tu peux nous dire oui oui
je peux le jeu peut le dire dans nos 23e
coup 33e 23.3 end on se dit c'est
l'intérêt 17 donc on va peut-être
avancer donc mais le temps pour les
noirs étaient très courts grâce trois
minutes pour atteindre le 40e coup donc
il faut mais comme c'est très tendu
c'est assez difficile de trouver les
bons coups à chaque fois donc ça c'est
un paramètre important du jeu d'échecs
de compétition c'est cette fameuse
pendule ou alors on va voir ensuite donc
tout reprend ses droits quand même donc
là c'est chou en trois minutes de temps
qui reste voilà c'est ça les fils de
pour la première partie en plus c'était
assez stressant et j'ai décidé de
sacrifier la qualité parce que je
pensais pouvoir arriver à trouver un
perpétuel donc le fameux shaker actuelle
qu'on va voir ce qu'on va sûrement voir
dans la partie puisque on en a parlé
tout à l'heure
l'alternative est reprend ses trois
étaient pas très emballante puisque je
pense qu'il s'agissait de tours j'ai 6
revient au g8
donc effectivement tôt procès trop avec
quasiment forcé alors voyons voyons la
suite à leurs pions prince et trois
grands tours et la d4 alors là c'est un
coup c'est un coup inattendu sacrifice
de pions encore en fait c'est surtout
pour libérer la case des 5 pour le
cavalier maintenant que le cavalier
libérer de la défense de la tour qui est
un g8 il peut participer pleinement à la
tacc d'accord et de dessins qui comptera
notamment la case c3 et la case 3 par
exemple le jour adam un échec 3d de et
d'un de ses trois échecs lancer un coup
libérateur pour cette pièce pour qu'elle
participe à la techno anna exact
d'ailleurs on y arrive alors pu
reprendre des quatre cavaliers des 5 et
en plus à contrôler bien les cases
noires ce qui est bien c'est a priori
c'est complémentaire du fou voilà et
comme la dame va plutôt faire des échecs
sur les cases main c'est quand même
assez utile d'accord donc la dame h8
échec au roi
donc le roi 17 alors pourquoi 17 et pas
c'est tout j'avais peur de tomber vite
je prends et en quoi après un échec sur
la case des six était obligée d'aller à
un 8c d'un certaines lignes c'était
assez gênant d'accord donc 3 17
donc là les blancs continuent aussi leur
harcèlement puisqu'il joue après trois
décès dont classe il ya les possibilités
convoi en cas de cadeaux royaux 7 dont 4
en 3d ces dames f8 là les blancs menace
le pion f7 oui je venais snam prend 1,7
et les dom prend tout et donc comme un
échec contre attaque des noirs au roi
des deux est forcé et la dame c3 donc là
c'est ça il est noir tu essaies de
pourchasser les blancs voilà deux seront
sur roissy 1 il y avait peut-être une
répétition de coût entre autres et la
france et 2 voilà en fait je laisse jean
marc effectuer sa menace d'un bref cette
dame 36 parce qu'une fois que la dame
sans je suis sûr à cavani f4 échec qui
fait fourchette à avoir là donc ça
s'appelle une défense
en direct c'est ça exact donc il ya une
fourchette qui menace qui prendrait la
dame en cas de prise
donc là jean marc à ce moment là tu es
toujours confiant puisque tu tu as le
sentiment de pouvoir tenir la partie
nord maintenant j'avais analysé je
pensais que c'était nul quoi j'avais vu
qu'il y avait chez que perpétuel à la
fin tu avais pas vu avant
si je l'avais vu avant mais je pouvais
rien faire d'accord étant laurent tu
l'avais vu avant tout de cette
combinaison tu l'avais vu où elle est
apparue
finalement après je vais penser avant de
jeu tout reprend ses trois mais comme un
moment là du tout alors j'avais très peu
de temps donc je les jouais très vite en
priant pour que jean montreux rien de
gagnant adacore donc en fait tu n'étais
pas sûr que de cette combinaison mais je
trouve qu'elle n'avait jamais rien vu de
bourges en main mais quand on n'a pas
beaucoup de temps on peut jamais être
sûr à 100% d'accord donc ça c'est bien
mais ça montre aussi que l'on voit pas
forcément tous dans une partie mais que
on joue sa chance à fond je pense que
c'était forcément plus d'accord donc on
va voir les coups suivants
donc faut prendre tour et adam trois
échecs
donc là roi f1 et la cavalière quatre
ans lorsqu'à cavaliers et triforce
ehsanullah le cavalier continue à
participer à l' attaque avec la dame
souvent c'est la dame et le cavaly c'est
un couple assez infernal quand on
attaque et là on menace dames deux
échecs 3g 1 et dames jeu de matt la
menace parce que vous prendrez un juste
avant pertes et en fait ce qu'on pouvait
tenter de prendre la tour il faut
prendre pour ça permettait de récupérer
une tour voilà mais il y avait un homme
prend 1,6 échec au roi c'est cette dame
des six échecs froissé 8 es fou et f5
mat
ah oui d'accord donc une combinaison de
maths carrément donc là le ca empêcher
qu'à 24 ans pêche cette comédie depuis
cinq ans à contrôler la presse aussi
tout simplement voilà ça défend aussi
donc ça y est super ce cavalier
puisqu'il ya la fois attaquants et
défenseurs en l1 et la l2 fonctions et
maintenant mon plan est rien et puis
défendu à ventabren aix 4 donc là du
sacrifice de c'est un sacrifice port
face et pas un sacrifice sinon je suis
mat
donc en fait c'est un sacrifice force et
oui c'est pour faire nul parce que en
fait jean marc a perdu la dame quoi
d'accord c'est toujours surprenant comme
ça de donner la dame ont toujours peur
et j'ai quand même deux tours et une
pièce pour la dame d'accord donc c'est
après d'un programme effectivement il
reste le fou ces deux qui est toujours
en prise par le fou g6 et donc
effectivement matériellement même les
blancs ont l'avantagé on peut dire on à
la wii ils sont gagnants c'est pour
enfin matériellement ils sont gagnants
maintenant la position du roi n'est
assez précaire voilà donc c'est là où
laurent on saute sur l'échec perpétuelle
c'est donc dans mes trois rouges et un
dmg trois échecs aux f1 d'un mais siii
encore échec et puis c'est une
répétition de position
donc là c'est ça s'appelle échec
perpétuelle puisqu'il n'y a pas moyen
d'échapper aux échecs on va forcément
répété la position autoroute heures donc
c'est une très jolie partie donc gros
studios de sueur froide pardon des deux
côtés j'ai l'impression oui moi j'étais
note en refuse donc c'était encore plus
stressant pour la première ronde d'un
nationale c'est assez difficile à vivre
et pourtant jean marc c'était peut-être
pas évident avec les blancs de faire nul
contre l' or entre qui a priori peu fait
pas partie des favorites utilisé de
cette partie oui j'espérais gagner cette
partie c'est sûr c'était une bon après
on se rattrape sur les six autres c'est
pas trop grave un bon mais je vous
remercie tous les deux pour cette
brillante analyse j'espère que vous
allez continuer vous continuez vos
espoirs puisque donc laurent tu vas
jouer en poule basse comme on dit entre
guillemets mais donc pour la suite de la
compétition et puis il part contre
jean-marc toi tu joues pour le titre
puisque tu vas jouer dans la foulée
grand chez les grands ont fait c'est de
gagner plus de parti possible
voilà donc avec quatre points tuez un
point des premiers tout est possible
tout est possible alors jeté dans merci
à vous d'avoir participé on va retrouver
maintenant on parlait des premiers il
est un des premiers de ce championnat
pour l'instant puisque c'est le grand
maître christian bauer qui va nous
rejoindre tout de suite avec accompagné
avec lui par robert fontaine robert
fontaine qui est un des plus jeunes
joueurs de ce national on en a parlé
tout à l'heure avec jean-claude
loubatière lors bonsoir à tous les deux
donc christian bauer bonsoir et donc
repères 31 ans en revers alors comment
ça s'est passé tous les deux là pour
pour ce national ont peut-être à bord
robert ont réservé christian pour la
suite donc robert fontaine donc c'est la
deuxième fois que tu fais nationale je
crois c'est ça oui la première fois
c'était à narbonne en 97 donc c'est les
filles pourquoi il faut rappeler que tu
es champion de france mais junior donc
c'est à dire que toi y est a priori un
des plus jeunes de ce tournoi avec
etienne bacrot et laurent frayssinet
ouais donc c'est pas facile déjà
jouer contre des joueurs qui ont plus
d'expérience et puis tu as a botté un
hello qui fait partie de la deuxième
moitié
je suis donc je suis dans les plus
faibles théoriquement donc c'est pas
facile oui mais c'est une expérience
quand même assez intéressante de chaleur
et de france
à noter que t'es pas qualifié pour la
provoc mais tu fais pas résultats
mauvais puisque tu fais un résultat en
conformité avec ton classement tu perd
pas de points alloués fort vu des
parties j'aurais pu espérer quand même
un peu mieux quoi donc gelé on est un
peu de regret des j'ai fait des parties
nulles voire perdre contre christian où
j'aurais pu avoir un demi point voire un
point de plus non mais c'est quoi donc
on aura sûrement l'occasion de voir ça
tout à l'heure alors christian bauer
alors on a présenté christian worner
avec que jean paul ii bâtir thème des
joueurs français qui actuellement marche
le mieux
tu as été au championnat de france
championnat du monde pardon de las vegas
c'est un des deux français qui étaient
là bas avec toujours le lotier ça fait
d'excellents résultats aussi jeunes aux
championnats d'europe par équipes c'est
ça et à l'open de new york juillet oui
et oui donc j'ai fait une perf à 2640 on
nous perdons une partie et l'open de new
york aussi ça ou c'est un bon tournoi
aussi pourtant oui je vais fait six
points et demi sur neuf et c'est pareil
j'avais fait une perf au dessus de 2006
où vous êtes mis 6 alors faut rappeler
dans ton classement c'est actuellement
ses 2500 62 points ce qui est pas mal du
tout ces projets 2006 savoir
qu'aujourd'hui aux échecs si on a du
2600 ou 2006 on est dans les 100
meilleurs joueurs du monde donc tu
t'approches un petit peu de cette barre
importante parce que s'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de joueurs et 2006 oui mais
effectivement c'est mon objectif pour le
prochain classement début janvier
d'avoir plus de 1600 et d'entrer dans
les 100 premiers mondiaux
alors tu es professionnel je crois
depuis pas longtemps tu as décidé de
passer le cap c'est ça depuis un an deux
ans de te consacrer à fond aux échecs
ça fait un an et demi exactement
donc depuis septembre à 98 et donc je
travaille un petit peu les échecs et
puis je oui je ne fais pratiquement que
ça d'accord alors en tête de cette poule
b
ça a été facile ou difficile aura gagné
donc contre robert conte avec nous
contre guillaume valin et contre manuel
a pissé là c'est ça et 3 et 4 nuls dans
les autres matches oui en fait j'ai
souffert dans deux parties contre
laurent frayssinet et puis contre un
atelier misère donc j'ai eu deux fois
des positions ainsi nettement inférieur
qu'il a fallu défendre et contre les
autres joueurs j'ai eu également
beaucoup de mal pour un pour gagner
contre robert notamment la première
ronde ils auraient dû faire mouche nul
et puis non mais il a fini par craquer
alors on va essayer justement de voir
puisque vous êtes là tous les deux cette
partie entre vous deux donc entre entre
christian bauer et donc robert fontaine
donc qu'ils avaient des plans dans cette
partie
j'avais les blancs d'accord dont une
partie tendue c'était à quelle ronde ce
que ça joue aussi l'impression puisque à
l'heure on avait jean marc degraeve
contre donc le rang guidara dit il
c'était la première c'était la première
et pour vous c'était votre affrontements
oui un des plus difficiles parce que -
la première ronde contrition avec les
noirs c'est quand même pas le meilleur
la meilleure nouvelle quoi la meilleure
nouvelle toiture et jouer contre eux qui
est un des plus faibles
un des plus faibles donc l'eau a priori
tu passes et christian parmi les parmi
les plus férus et avec dorfman et
fraissignes alors on voit tout de suite
cette partie là sur notre écran de
contrôle
18 c'est quoi 18 c'est le nombre de
minutes c'est ça l'accord ok donc on va
on va donc suivre cette partie dans les
18 pour la compte comme anti elle sait
combien de coups 70 80 90 81 donc on va
avancer rapidement on va voir d'avoir
l'ouverture est rapidement pour la
nommer ce jour d'ouverture
donc ça c'est une défense karo kann je
crois c'est ça voilà donc j'ai joué des
d3e deuxième coup ce qui est pas très
fréquent donc ouais c'est quoi ce choix
alors été pour moi commenté ce choix
d'ouverture après on avancera vers la
fin pour voir le moment intéressant la
partie belle chose était de jouer
quelque chose de ses calmes et d'éviter
le
les préparations de robert comme c'est
une première ronde je voulais pas
embarquer dans quelque chose de très
connu d'accord être pour toi robert
c'était une surprise c'est une coudée 3
je m'attendais pas du tout à ça je pense
que tu l'a jamais joué christian donc
nous avons est bon c'est pas trop
effrayant plus boîte
d'accord on est assez calme après ce qui
l'a aidé à éviter la préparation donc
d'accord ok donc on va on va suivre
cette ouverture tranquillement peut-être
le lillois avait fait pas que tu peux
être commentée aussi rapidement cette
partie oui bah download et provoqua des
points 4 voilà le forfait est bloqué ici
et robert joue à cinq je pense que ça a
l'air pas mal pour les noirs puisque
puisque ici ils ont joué ils ont égalisé
au niveau de la structure de pions et
maintenant on s'aventure vers une partie
qui a l'air qui a l'air je dis bien
assez ennuyeuse puisque c'est symétrique
et il se passe apparemment pas grand
chose mais enfin ça doit être plein de
subtilité pour ma part je ne comprends
pas très bien ce genre de position donc
je vais laisser vous je vais vous
laisser parler voilà mais je crois que
christina un expert de ce type de
position un peu un peu bizarre non oui
enfin là elle n'est pas si bizarre que
ça et puis effectivement elle est très à
plat n'y est a priori pas très
intéressante les types de l'habitude de
le jouer cette position celle là
exactement non mais enfin je suis pas
spécialement gêné par les structures un
petit peu symétrique
alors qu'elle est aux mains de la partie
peut-être pas dans quelle loi fait
dérouler les coûts quel moment de la
partie qui le plus le plus intéressant
peut-être vers la fin où je sais pas le
moment clip party moi je pense que ça si
tu vends le 40e puisqu'il y avait un
léger détail note est bon ça s'est joué
à peu près par la cua ça s'est joué par
le 40e alors peut-être on va on va
arriver à cette position alors nous
arrêter vous arrêtez le h5 la gamme a5
s'est étendu oui ça sert à ça rien le
meilleur coup je pense qu'il faut
revenir avec le cavalier en abscisse
d'accord mais on peut voir que robert
pouvait prendre le cavalier h4rem faire
des pions doublé oui mais dans ce cas là
il aurait eu quelques quelques
faiblesses sur son propre rock à savoir
que le pion angers 6 et des cases noires
sont faibles oui et donc c'était pas
très pas très gênant enfin je craignais
pas vraiment fou projet d'accord du coup
peut-être oublié de se servir de ce pion
à prêt pour attaquer toi même le roc et
demi oui la trash 58 pour attaquer les
revoilà éventuellement aussi la colonne
jay par un rush insurgés d'accord mais
tu peux pas peur de cette de cet échange
donc à stein qui a priori pas utile
avant peut-être eloi tu peux continuer
on va essayer d'aller vite parce que
vraiment on a eu peu de minutes pour
essayer de commenter les moments
intéressants de cette partie on va
essayer d'arriver vers le verbe 40e coup
premier peut-être premier passage vers
ce 40e ou qui vont faire un deuxième
passage
autour de 70 m lancé ça oui mais voir un
peu voilà donc en suisse donc c'est une
partie on va commenter de façon générale
on va pas rentrer dans le détail
peut-être l'âme ou a l'impression qu'il
ya beaucoup de nouveaux noms c'est à
dire qu'il ya heureusement des pièces on
a vu le cavalier qui appartient la fuite
qui revient aux six donc on cherche la
meilleure place pour les billets c'est
ça d'ailleurs je pensais que c'était y
aller j'ai proposé à près de tournai 1 à
christian jeu proposé nu l'agression
mais il voulait pas la première ronde
oui voilà même si j'ai des peuples
particulièrement satisfait de la
tournure des événements ici à la presse
de fausses et 7 à mon avis je dois
changer les fous par cavalier 17
d'accord qu'a dit hier à mon avis
s'attend vraiment vers la nulle
maintenant d'accord pour essayer
d'échanger le fou h4 avec le malin
d'accord mais effectivement c'est
difficile mm d'imaginer que les blancs
puisse faire des menaces puisque
l'option détroit est arriérée et si on
échange les fous on va jouer après
prononcé cinq et on n'a plus grand chose
à défendre côté noir en tout cas en tout
cas ça a l'air assez tranquille
tranquille pour les noirs tout le monde
est d'accord alors lentilles on continue
donc poussé cette voie la b4 et à 6 c je
pense que c'est vraiment une erreur
parce que j'ai subi toutes les dames
avec ce coup et christian on va trouver
il va me fixer en fait sur cases noires
ce qui va être très désagréable par la
suite donc là c'est alors par contre à 5
c'est intéressant parce que c'est un
pion passé pour les noirs raisin oui
mais c'est peut-être une erreur je pense
qu'ils en pensent christian peut-être
que je pense qu'il fallait plutôt
prendre mes 5
parce que oui en fait le pion le pion à
5 et fait un peu peur comme ça parce
qu'il est passé protéger mais comme il
va être bloquée
très rapidement il n'est pas il ne
constitue pas vraiment une menace à et
donc simplifier la position par un pion
prendre les cinq avaient l'épreuve des 5
était peut-être meilleur d'accord et on
aurait aussi aimé bien passé en plus
toujours en b si fou profit ce donc là
c'est un choix un choix important
puisque on décide d'arriver dans enfin
de donner un fou contre un cavalier ça
change radicalement le
en tout cas le combat qui était en train
de se dérouler puisque le matériel les
plus équilibrés et je pense que les
blancs jouent clairement contre le
mauvais fond ans et 7 qui est bloqué par
ses propres pions donc en fait on a deux
cavaliers contre cavaliers et mauvais
fou donc petit avantage blanc c'est ça
sert que les pions blancs sont quasi
sûrs sont placés sur casse blanche si ça
c'est surtout le oui enfin plutôt dans
l'autre sens les pions noirs sont sur 15
mois en accord ce qui limite le foot
recasement d'accord donc cavalier échec
alors le g7 mais on va quand même
prendre le fou parle sur cavaliers c7
jeu reprend et j'attaque le pion mais
cinq d'accord donc on ne s'est pas
envisageable
oh c'était possible mais chaud chaud et
voire mieux quand même pour les non
d'accord donc là les noirs continuent
le problème c'est que le coeff 6 voilà
ça met toujours un pion socas noir voilà
on voit que le foot des 8 marion est
complètement dominé par le cahier des
cinq contrôles les cas on voit que à 5
c'était vraiment pas utile du tout quoi
là par contre robert avait un choix
s'était joué cavalier c7 d'accord pour
échanger lecavalier des cinq qui est
très fort et après essayer de me mettre
en valeur le pion un passif d'accord
pour faire diversion dont canon sur ssl
ses droits ses 4 l'accord dont presse
cécile partir de là on a vu une partie
plus violente avec une attaque contre le
roi là c'est le type de parti qu'il faut
aussi commander parce que il ya beaucoup
de partis aussi de ce style là qui est
rentré dans une finale assez vite
finalement une position plus ou moins
symétrique
donc c'est vraiment le la vision à long
terme et les plans à long terme de
placement de pièces qui sont importants
oui c'est une partie a tourné en plus
stratégique que celle que je marche qui
est le leur en ont joué d'accord donc
alors peut-être les lois tu peux
continuer on peut voir avancer la suite
en est on à quels coûts là est-ce qu'on
peut ce qu'on peut savoir à peu près oui
on te savoir on est au 37e coup est donc
ici ça a commencé en interrogeant les
40e coup fatidique on l'a dit donc là il
reste peu de temps aux deux joueurs
c'est ça toujours pareil ce il ya le
late note
il reste peu de temps pour la nation
qu'il arrive il ya ma position qui se
dégradent petit à petit et et le 40e en
plus donc ça commence vraiment à faire
beaucoup
alors là les blancs vont peut-être
augmenter la pression sur le plan des
six avec le cavalier qui peut les sur la
casse ces cartes c'est ça il voulait que
la vallier qui attaquent bêtise
effectivement c'est ce que j'ai joués
qui avait laissé quatre ans donc robert
avec de chemin en fait la jouer cavalier
clac qu'il a fait je pense que c'est moi
j'ai choisi ce qui est une erreur c'est
une erreur pourquoi alors pas cavalier
protège des six finalement mais ils
attaquent à placer sa part le roi en
fait ils déjà ils bloquent le pion passé
et ensuite
ensuite il va être arrivé là pour le
reste de la partie parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre moyen de protéger le pion de
l'isr variante d'ailleurs qu'ils seront
très risqués pour moi puisque
quand christian jours à f4 ça va libérer
la case des 4 es mon cavalier n'aura
plus le cas c'est à dire que dès qu'il
sera attaqué par le roi moncava y en a 4
sera piégé donc si tu l'avais pas vu
dans la dans la précipitation musique
note il est tout à fait d'accord donc on
va voir la suite des coups droits b3
attaque le quart il ya 4 puis 6 une
imprécision aussi ça revient on revient
maintenant c'était pour répéter des
coupons s'il aurait pu jusqu'à 17 à ce
moment là voilà encore oui mais comme il
restait dans son erreur c'est ça il venu
4 d'accord donc ça c'est dommage parce
que oui mais on ne se rend pas compte de
l'accord de ces choses à quand donc la
voir aussi ce et ensuite voilà f4 donc
ça c'est un coup alors ça c'est
important aussi tu position c'est trop
tard il faut essayer de créer une
tension de rupture une ouverture oui sur
un second front
et donc là en fait l'idée c'était de
dévier le pion au sein comme l'a dit
robert donc j'ai plus moi même joué d3
d4 en levant la dernière case aux
cavaliers dans le casting est donc ici
j'ai réfléchi très longtemps pour
essayer de le poser g5 pour jouer f5
d'essayer de déstabiliser un peu
christian de donner le pion aux 5 et
d'avoir un peu de jeu pour mon fou en
font un des huit qui vraiment ridicule
pour l'instant donc mais ça marche pas
malheureusement donc après g5 je suis
réduit à la défense vraiment au total
quoi donc
f5 échec roi en 17 donc là on peut voir
aussi que
géométriquement parlant les lions blancs
sont vraiment bien placé son casse
blanche et bloque les pions noirs sur
leurs cases noires le food évident ne
sert à rien enfin protéger ses pions une
série
voilà une serre jusqu'en de défense il
peut il peut pas avoir un rôle actif
alors là il ya une triangulation ce qui
fait qu'on a fait on a donné le très
haut noire les noirs qui n'ont pas
vraiment de coup dans cette position
puisque le fou des beats défend les deux
pions donc ne peut pas bouger et les
blancs en fait force le roi noir a
reculé sur la case de 8 ou ses huit
puisque ce recueil c5 évidemment je
pense comprendre et pion b6 donc on peut
revoir la manoeuvre peut-être voilà
c'était comme ça
le roi est en c2 bonjour wab et 3,7 au
plan de jouer et ses cinq échecs roi c3
il faut revenir pour défendre l'option
v6 donc l audi a4 échec roi ces deux on
est dans la même position sauf que c'est
au noir de jouer donc on a gagné du
terrain avec les blancs puisque le roi
noir doit partir voilà pour jouer le roi
et le roi va assez vite alors qu'avec
des six alors c'est quoi l'idée sky va
essayer d'attaquer les plantes de
l'autre côté c'est ça oui puisqu'il ne
s'est échangé contre le fou des huit qui
protège le pion m6 qu'il en existe plein
de l'ancien dispensaire tombe il ya le
solde de nbc sur les pcistes qui va
tomber
voilà subtilement en fait c'est ce
qu'avaient les des scènes qui vend
domine la position et c'est exactement
donc si c'est dur de jouer robert une
position comme ça de défense d'abord
parce qu'on peut tenir ce type de
position
non je pense pas parce que les blancs
n'ont aucune chance de perdre donc il
peut travailler la position pendant un
temps assez long et moi je peux rien
faire donc
à long terme je pense que ça va perdre
de toute manière donc tout comme
toulouse est parti à ce moment là tu
penses que tu vas perdre autant de route
oui je suis chiant genre pourquoi tu
continues à feu et pour voir quand même
si sur toi quand même c'est à dire oui
mais christian essai
c'est fort pour flinguer ses positions
je continue quand même pour voir sa
manoeuvre de gains parce qu'à ce moment
là c'est pas c'est pas si clair que ça
attaque mais déjà il resterait but de
l'espoir renaisse voilà cette position
est d'accord mais bon c'est un peu plus
par parnac quoi d'accord donc on cherche
la recherche arnaque
voilà mais ici c'est fini maintenant
puisqu'il va attaquer le plus 1,6 avec
ses deux cavaliers et on voit que j'ai
pas d'accord voilà sa longévité
voilà ça va être dur on peut par le roi
des forêts que le roi repasse par aux
8es f7 c'est ça mais voilà c'est quoi
c'est compliqué il faut celle d'un cran
en voilà donc la cavalier j'ai vite et
la sai on voit que le purin fils va
tomber donc h4 on prend h4 et après
voilà ça y est l'option existence donc
là c'est toute la structure des noirs
content parce que maintenant le pion aux
5es faibles tout à fait des caves six
tombes tout tombe donc donc là c'est dur
en tout cas est encore quelques coups
donc en fait mais là tu l'as tu
conscient que ça va être plus où ils
jouissent epernay oui oui d'ailleurs
robert jeu mais très vite à ce moment-là
opine
on n'est plus d'accord donc si une
victoire finalement ce qu'on a à me dire
que vous étiez en masse la terre
certains oui mais si j'aurais préféré
gagner plus de façon plus spectaculaire
mais bon comme vous remercier d'être m a
défendu au début je n'aime pas trop le
choix
d'accord donc là c'est fini
est ce qu'on arrive à la position finale
eloi peut-être une autre fini c'est fini
donc c'est la position finale ça oui
donc là donc alors comment on peut
résumer cette partie alors ça c'est
intéressant parce qu'on a eu 2 2
oppositions de style dans les deux
parties on n'a pas le temps de commenter
une partie aussi longue mais ça arrive
souvent c'est parti il faut gagner
souvent
ce niveau-là de jeu à l'arraché c'est
pas évident de gagner des points si on
va pas jusqu'au bout
donc comment comment ça s'est passé
comment se passe ce type de parti dans
l'espoir de gains du joueur belge et
surtout bénéficié du manque de temps de
me robert je pense parce que s'il avait
plus de temps il nous retrouver
cavaliers 17 au lieu de cavalia 4
d'accord et à ce moment là il fallait
tout refaire et c'était peut-être déjà
déjà nul d'accord donc là la pression du
temps à décider sûrement de la partie
donc c'est important de gérer bien son
temps aux échecs oui ça c'est sûr
d'accord robert aussi tu penses que
c'était le moment clé finalement le ski
a décidé la partie c'est plus que la
position c'est le manque de temps oui
tout à fait qu'il fait mais j'ai
vraiment très lentement dans le début
parce que ce qu'elle joue et s'était
complètement atypique et je connaissais
pas du tout donc j'ai dû prendre
beaucoup de temps pour retrouver un plan
un bon placement pour mes pièces est bon
je les payais par la suite quoi d'accord
donc c'était alors ensuite bon on a vu
cette partie peut-être vous pouvez nous
raconter votre votre tournoi commence à
s'est déroulée pour les pour les
partitions dans peut-être christian ça
s'est bien passé ça me till puisque tu
en tête actuellement donc tu vas
rejoindre la poule haute et
avec 5 points à égalité donc avec armand
aux sharks a fait aussi un excellent
début de tournoi et
comment ça s'est passé c'est ce début
vers c'est bien parti donc avec cette
victoire
oui donc le tournoi s'est plutôt bien
passé jusque là pendant mais comme je
l'avais dit au début les parties que
j'ai gagné j'ai dû travailler dur contre
guillaume valence était égal pendant
quarante coups à peu près avant qu'il
fasse une erreur et contrevenu à l'appui
c'est là pendant très longtemps aussi
plus de trente coups c'était équilibré
et avant qu'il fasse aussi des des
imprécisions et donc ça c'est quand même
pas mal pas mal déroulés il ya pas eu de
grosses frayeurs dans sa première partie
oui et non enfin contre contre leur
rentrée ciné contre weiser c'était des
choses c'est délicat d'accord et pour
toi robert après cette défaite c'est pas
évident de démarrer avec une défaite sur
un championnat ça c'est vrai pour tous
les sports il vous faut aussi au tennis
aussi mais d'ailleurs j'ai fait une
seule et même éliminé d'ailleurs mais
bon je la salue on peut jouer quand même
oui donc ce pour ce gène chez suivi par
autre nul donc j'essaie de j'essayais de
plus perdre et gagner c'est pas facile
contre compte des gars comme ça ensuite
j'ai encore perdu contre genre un décor
au bout encore de 7 heures de jeu donc
un peu comme en construction et j'ai
terminé par un nul et une victoire
finalement donc bon g - 1 par rapport à
la moyenne
donc c'est pas terrible mais bon j'ai
pas beaucoup perdu ça aurait pu être
pire après la première ronde quoi ai-je
et j'aurais pu quand même à voir
j'ai eu des positions gagnantes que j'ai
pas concrétisées donc bon tant pis voilà
bon on a un peu les deux extrêmes donc
d'autres difficultés pour robert mais
ces bébés au site à l'avenir devant toi
christophe un peu plus âgé donc les
moins avenir devant lui mais il y en a
plus y en a quand même un très beau
puisque donc déjà les
la poule haute qui se dessine donc avec
un très bon très bon avantage au départ
c'est un point avec l'égalité avec
arnaud donc on aura sûrement l'occasion
de revoir christian la suite de ces
événements donc on vous rappelle qu'on
est là donc jusqu'à la fin de ce tournoi
donc 70 soit dimanche éventuellement en
cas d'égalité il y aura des matchs de
départage donc tous les soirs rendez
vous à 21h sur canal avec donc les
champions analyse des partis et
résultats complets donc moi je vous
donne rendez vous pour la suite donc
bravo christian pour ce très bon début
du tournoi et puis à bientôt donc on
espère 3 voir sur le plateau dans les
jours prochains et robert aussi donc
bonne suite de ce important aussi c'est
poule basse il faut faire un bon
résultat pour pas il faut avoir une
place dans la forêt noire puisqu'il ya
quand même des choses à gagner c'est de
l'argent bien peu d'argent gagné voilà
donc je vous donne congé merci à vous
d'être d'être passé moi je vous dis donc
à demain 21h sur diagonale pour voir la
suite de de ce tournoi je sais pas si on
peut envoyer le générique en avant et
donc